estabilidad económica y bienestar social
esos son los principales desafíos del
recién electo presidente de costa rica
rodrigo chávez fue ministro de hacienda
durante apenas seis meses en la
presidencia de carlos alvarado su
partido progreso social democrático
tiene sólo tres años de fundado y no se
esperaba ni siquiera que superará la
primera ronda aún así fue el ganador
inesperado de unas elecciones que
arrojaron una abstención histórica
superior al 42 por ciento esto no
significa bajo ningún punto de vista que
los compatriotas que no acudieron a las
urnas no amen a costa rica ni a su
democracia ellos son probablemente los
más críticos y preocupados por el futuro
del país aceptó esa advertencia
como un compromiso para trabajar con más
fuerza y patriotismo por costa rica
el economista conservador que obtuvo
menos de un quinto de los escaños en el
parlamento necesitará generar amplios
consensos para cumplir con la promesa de
mejorar los indicadores sociales que una
vez hicieron de costa rica- un referente
en américa latina' con esta minoría
política con apenas 10 escaños sobre 57
como el gobierno podrá justamente llevar
a cabo la reforma fiscal que costa rica
necesita para poder aumentar sus
ingresos y por ende también tener
mayores recursos para generar mayores
políticas sociales
chávez también debe responder a
acusaciones e irregularidades en el
financiamiento de su candidatura y sobre
acoso sexual durante su paso por el
banco mundial luego de una campaña
caracterizada por la confrontación no ha
perdido tiempo para comenzar a tender
puentes no hay espacio para el
resentimiento menos para los
revanchismos o las confrontaciones
estériles
comprendo que en una campaña electoral
se dicen muchas cosas pero yo me he
comprometido
y me empeñaré en impulsar profundos y
positivos cambios en la forma de
gobernar costa rica-
democráticamente
y reparar los daños que la pandemia
produjo en la economía fundamentalmente
en el turismo será la primera tarea que
chávez tendrá que atender desde el 8 de
mayo cuando asuma la presidencia